folks you voted on Twitter and so even
though the Obermann video is ready to go
it will be released next Thursday for
today let's talk about Casey Anthony
Weiner now I know some of you are upset
but if you didn't want this video you
should be following me on Twitter at s
Crowder so you can vote plus it's my
birthday and I really wanted to talk
about this I'm doing a well I used to be
23 for those of you wondering why I
didn't just say 24 I wanted to do the
number 3 like the rapper's do they don't
do it in the most easily signed
internationally-recognized way to do it
they do it like this they don't play by
anyone's rules so Casey Anthony a lot of
people are upset by the media circus
surrounding it and as one who works in
the media I feel your pain and believe
me the irony isn't lost on me that I'm
adding to that discussion right now but
whether we like it or not it's in the
news now and Morrissey had a post up at
hot air discussing that Casey Anthony
might have gotten more press coverage
than any GOP candidate so let's talk
about it in jujitsu this into a learning
tool now if you're looking for some
guilty not guilty Monday Morning
Quarterback nonsense to shut this off
and go turn on a cable news network
there are plenty of legal analyst with
their obligatory comb-overs doing it
there frankly I wasn't on the jury so I
can't know if she did it or not either
way she was still like millions of
mothers out there unfit to parent a
child but let's say for the sake of
argument that she did do it we do know
that Casey wanted to party and be a wild
cow and felt burdened by her kid
ultimately her kid didn't make her happy
and so people are shocked that she would
be so selfish as to mistreat or kill her
child firstly how is any different from
mothers who kill their baby in their
womb in order to avoid inconvenience in
their own personal happiness or murder
not withstanding at the root of the
problem how is it any more selfish from
the mother who walks out on her family
to find herself oh my god I just need to
Center myself I need to find me find
that balance you know yoga what I want
to know is when did one's personal
happiness become the ultimate value and
why today do we allow it to supersede
all other values I'd like to read you a
quote here from The Satanic Bible and no
you don't have to believe in God or the
devil
to understand my point most Satanists
believe in neither there is no heaven of
glory bright no hell were sinners roast
here and now with our day of torment
here and now is our day of joy here and
now is our opportunity choosy this day
this hour for no Redeemer liveth you're
really interchangeable with modern
atheism or a lot of situational ethics
now when you Satan I'm just using the
example in Hebrew it means the adversary
of God and this adversary tells you that
your happiness is what's most important
you are the God of your own universe no
I'm not saying we shouldn't be happy
it's our moral obligation to be grateful
and nobody loves a grumpy old man
so stem scrawls are at my bird feeder
again but when I see praise for people
absolving themselves of responsibilities
in the name of their own happiness it
rubs me the wrong way
counterclockwise how could Casey Anthony
be so selfish what you encourage the
same pattern of selfish behavior with
Eat Pray Love how could Anthony Weiner
do this to his wife you've made
philandering Brad Pitt and Angelina
society's golden couple
see when whatever makes you happy
becomes the barometer then all morality
can become subjective whether it's
Anthony's wiener or Casey Anthony oh my
god Jessica you need to leave him you
know take some time for yourself
you need to take some you time Jessica
just do what makes you happy how about
instead we start doing what's right